welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
Mandalorian chapter 23 season 3 episode
7 the spies from Shadow Council cameos
to Clues the armor might be up to
something I'm gonna break down this
episode shot by shot for all the details
you might have missed and subscribe to
my new channel the Deep dive for deeper
analyzes into titles like Christopher
Nolan's Interstellar I think my favorite
video I've ever made a second to this
one you're about to watch and thank you
to boxu for sponsoring this video more
on their tasty offerings later okay we
open on the Rainy lower levels of
Coruscant looking particularly more
blade runnery than usual especially with
Elijah Kane and her raised trench coat
color particularly cruel since her
victim Dr Pershing adopted this look
back in chapter 19. now this is a part
of Coruscant that we would have explored
in the 1313 game and the constantly
being developed Star Wars underworld
from Ronald D Moore Creator Battlestar
Galactica would have been such a good
show and the orabesh on all the neon
signs translate to things most of them
misspelled words like vertical in pink
is Sai Bene tiox I thought it said
cybernetics which would make sense but
no that fifth letter is not an R it's an
n and that is definitely an O after the
I the Cyber antiox isn't anything in
Star Wars and kind of like that orbash
meta message to us YouTubers last
episode that added a p to the word
however sometimes they just don't spell
it right so why do I even bother what's
because I'm a know-it-all and this is
the way so let's keep going to the right
vertical and blue further back either
food or EDU depending on which way you
go toward the bottom in white the word
play on the left vertical and blue
something ents then over on the right
horizontal and yellow ahkq beneath that
vertical and blue Bronwyn I assume one
of the VFX starred as daughters or
girlfriends and beneath those texts
angled on a corner in white
g-r-q-l-u-s and then across that alley
vertical in green aojrn across the alley
vertical and red again 70 TX not
cybernetics and then in front of that
horizontal inpeg fdg as in dumbass waste
of time this was as a lion king rounds
the corner across the street in red
circles the word alley and then blue
vertical calf c-a-f huh actual words
calf is the Indian verse name for coffee
in Star Wars and then triangles light up
with look then at then me look at me I
am changing and Imperial probe Droid
with an evil red eye like the droids it
went bad on Pleasure last episode or
like Hal until Space Odyssey finds Kane
and scans her face with one of those
awesome blue scanners like Carson Davis
Droid had at the end of chapter 21 like
the probes at the beginning of James
Cameron's aliens look so cool MAF Kitty
and Tyler projection beams out in open
air he is an escaped war criminal but I
guess this is safer for Lion King than
her amnesty housing unit and we learned
that the pirate nation of gorion Shard
was aligned with mob Gideon's
pro-imperial conspiracy and then Gideon
grumbles upon hearing that the night
owls of ax Wolves and the children of
the watch have combined forces under the
leadership of bocatan Crees this episode
is titled the spies plural and to be a
spy you have to be someone with the
duplicitous agenda so after Elia Kane
who was the other spy of this episode an
argument could be made for the armorer
and I will make it but since ax wolves
wasn't present for Gideon's arrest in
chapter 16 and conveniently ended up
with Gideon's light Cruiser I think he
might be the other spy someone is simply
loyal to Gideon so long as Gideon could
pay up that could be why Gideon here
asks rich mandalorians and he denies
that any Mandalorian would cooperate
with each other he's gonna make a call
to his he acts and X is gonna be like
what man I made a really great speech
about the darksaber and all these idiots
I hang out with read Harry Potter and
think the Elder one logic made sense so
Gideon walks through his base with red
shield walls opening up like that corner
on Naboo and Phantom Menace when they're
fighting Darth Maul effectively this
creates a tiered security system like
you know the opening sequence of get
smart because rooms open up between each
of these red shield walls but only
Gideon has access to the furthest Inner
Room each gate is flanked by
Stormtroopers with a new generation of
armor best guard we later learned shaped
to look like the first order
Stormtrooper design he passes tanks
containing obscure figures these look
like further attempts at snoke strand
casts like on the Navarro Basin chapter
12 like those folks who keep yeasts and
jars all over their homes this is just
something Gideon does in his spare time
to try to be the first with a winner now
since this face is on Mandalore these
guys could be stewing In Living Waters
taken from the Springs where the
mythosar was Gideon's whole agenda is to
take the best of all cultures cloners
Jedi mandalorians and to use all these
things to feed the first order so why
not throw in some Mando Dasani we meet
captain
a hugely important figure from Star Wars
Legends starting with Timothy zahn's
heir to the Empire thrawn novels which
he's thrawn's Protege and he looks
exactly like this mustache Insignia it's
got that lowered cap that pompous pout
he's played by the perfectly cast Xander
Berkeley Gregory from The Walking Dead
and a ton of other roles this is the
first time we've seen Captain Pelion in
live action after a brief vocal cameo in
Rebels
hyperspace I've never seen and his
appearance here tells us that thrawn is
coming thrawn briefly appeared in the
Ahsoka trailer and is confirmed to be
played by Lars Mickelson the thrawn
voice actor from Rebels and apparently
showed his face in some bonus Ahsoka
footage shown exclusively at Star Wars
celebration Helen urges the others to
present themselves as unorganized
Remnant Warlords a bit of justification
for how the first order was able to rise
under the new Republic's nose during
this period he also says Grand Admiral
thrawn's returnable Herald in the
re-emergence of our military and provide
commandant hux enough time to deliver on
Project Necromancer so part of pelion's
strategy is to wait for thrawn to return
so the Imperial Fleet will have a
popular wartime leader that will rally
more to their cause speaking of the
importance of singular military leaders
in real world history to Rally the base
kind of like George Washington and the
Revolutionary Army and Robert E Lee to
the Confederate Army meanwhile coming
down tux is brindle hux father to
Armitage hooks played Here by Brian
Gleason brother to Armitage hux actor
Domino Gleason they kept it in the
family and it's just perfect casting the
2017 novel phasma by Delilah s Dawson
explores the early years of the first
order in the Royal brindle Hooks and
Armitage hux played in recruiting child
soldiers as first order Stormtroopers as
was the case for Finn and Janna from
Rise of Skywalker but now we learn that
brindlehux also oversees project
Necromancer so necromancy refers to the
black magic Art of communicating with
the dead or resurrecting their spirits
and this is their code word for the Sith
Eternal plot to resurrect Palpatine via
cloning so instead of somehow Palpatine
returned now we get project Necromancer
but brindle accuses Gideon of making
this a bit extracurricular Gideon has
been conducting his own cloning research
with Dr Pershing on Navarro something
that he hasn't cc'd Huck's on suggesting
that Gideon hoped to go over brindle's
head to be the warlord with the first
cocktail of high M count blood to
resurrect Palpatine also interesting
detail notice hux and Pelion are the
only two of these Warlords to wear
classic Imperial uniforms the others
don't have the benefit of strong navies
with thick holes to command from these
others have to get by on scrap that
sometimes have to hide in plain sight
Gideon cast doubt on thrawn's return
talking about him as if he was a ghost
that they all need to move on from which
will either bite Gideon in the ass or
maybe it's a sign that thrawn's arc on
Ahsoka might have nothing to do with the
first order which is kind of what I'm
hoping for honestly make the guy a rogue
sorry paleon I just don't think that guy
cares that much about what's going on
here Gideon has sent in a request for
three praetorian guards reinforcements
and reinforcements for his Thai
interceptors and bombers from Pelion now
the praetorian guards are the red suited
first order Warriors that stood by snoke
in The Last Jedi with all their melee
weapons in my opinion the most badass
fighters in the sequel Trilogy so
excited to see more of these guys and
the name praterian guards actually comes
from ancient Rome why does Gideon want
these well he did lose a hand-to-hand
duel with din jarin he knows he can't
keep up in any kind of melee situation
so with a smart request Gideon says I am
increasingly confident
that they are preparing to retake their
home world of Mandalore and yeah again I
don't think we realize that when we're
first watching this episode right now
Gideon is currently on Mandalore I'm
pretty sure that this facility with its
rock walls is close to that great Forge
location that we end the episode on so
the others don't want Gideon's best
guard mining operation disrupted they
all need it now remember in past
episodes visitors to Mandalore had no
communication from the surface we
thought it was just from the weather
patterns but it might actually have been
part of a signal jamming process emitted
by Gideon to keep their operation hidden
presumably Gideon set this up after the
purge after all the mandalorians were
gone from the planet using Imperial
propaganda that this planet was cursed
and radioactive to keep people away from
it now when you're watching your
favorite movies and shows they've got
your eyes and ears covered but what
about your other senses for that you
need a snack and if you want snacks that
are as immersive and transformative as a
big Blockbuster film or a great
streaming show you want baksu baksu is a
premium Japanese snack box that works
with family businesses all over Japan to
deliver a new theme of authentic
Japanese snacks every month beyond the
tasty treats each box you comes with a
booklet that teaches you all about the
theme and where the snacks come from so
take a look this theme is thesis of
Japan this will be your first box it
tells you where all the treats come from
in the different parts of Japan lots of
great information about them I'm gonna
try this white strawberry from Nagano
it's produced exclusively for boxes the
only place you can get it
look it's a little dried strawberry but
oh my God
I love this the thing is many of Japan's
most unique flavors are seasonal so
everything in here is carefully designed
to bring you the best of those four
seasons and another great thing about
boxer is that when you fall in love with
a snack like I just did you could stock
up on your favorites through baksu
Boutique both eye and the new Rockstar's
office have been receiving these boxes
for ages and we love them they also make
a stellar gift for the food or travel
lover in your life so if you want to try
baksu and support the channel click the
link in the description and use the code
rockstars to get 15 off your order okay
onto Navarro the locals are cleaning up
after that pirate attack in chapter 21.
I don't say the wreckage of gorian
shard's Corsair anywhere back there but
you know VFX is expensive they all look
up to see what is it what is it it's an
imperial light Cruiser but actually no
this is mock Gideon's Old Ship now with
its underbelly repainted with a red
mythosar skull by axwell's division the
time they must have taken to paint that
now while grief cargo makes it seem like
this is one of the few times a massive
ship overhead is it meant to evoke fear
again we are still waiting to find out
expo's true loyalties here so I think
that sense of fear is intentional here
as Bogota boards we first see her dark
saber now hanging from her hips
something that you know the members of
the watch must notice immediately the
armor bangs her hammer on her tongs
recreating that music she talked about
remember hearing from the great Forge
behind her that crate is labeled in the
Mandola language on the side that's the
numbers one zero two four and then on
the front a mythosar and the word ammo
grief cargo gifts Bando with what looks
like some course on its scotch and a
rebooted ig-11 who enters at the side at
first to reveal it's actually being
piloted by an enzelan Droid Smith pretty
unsettling to see this guy's exposed ass
and his calves as he climbs out a group
who looks up from that bowl of candy
that he was munching on in chapter 17.
and he Coos when he sees his old squeeze
bad baby
it's pretty cute to see grogu being worn
by this IG Droid like a Bjorn I'll go
back to an ig11 saved grogu and wore him
that way at the end of season one but
now grogu operates ig-12 like a mech
suit giving the child control over his
movement he can finally keep up and stop
fights I guess but few things bring me
more joy than the idea of grogu punching
yes and no on repeat like a pet
soundboard to ask for food but in roku's
case it's opportunity to say yes yes yes
and yes just to show how happy he is
feeling on every step of this Droid yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
so Goku just starts pigging out on food
from a vendor and he grabs a melaroon
fruit that he squeezes all over this
tarson's Merchant no squeezy at the
feast they roast on a spit what looks
like either an eopi or a kadu I thought
it was one of those winged reptilian
creatures but I don't see any Wings here
the two sides sit apart from each other
the peacetime sigil of House visla its
red-leafed branch on a white Banner
hangs over where they sit but bogoton
says it's time for all of them to retake
Mandalore saying dormant species have
been awakened by the bombings including
mythosar and another big boy we meet
this episode she proposes that they go
to Mandalore while she leads a scouting
party asking for volunteers Nevada
doesn't them volunteer as tribute
including the armorer I will go as well
yeah there's a shady sound effect that
plays as the armorer steps up not sure
if it's meant to convey bogoton's
respect for her or for us to cast doubt
on the Armor's motives as they all look
down at the ruins of mandalorian's list
says it's worse than he thought and the
guy next to him says I was here when it
happened yikes say more friend as the
camera pushes into din Jara and all this
blue helmets sitting in a row shake
their heads in astonishment bogoton
orders to search for the forge they
start scouting in that direction
warm up she looks so happy I don't think
we've ever seen her smile this much but
the armor heel turns behind her
obviously impossible to tell her
expression but she's definitely more
reserved and ponderous than Bo Katan is
the sky they March under has these
clouds that rapidly zip toward them kind
of like a terrestrial hyperspace they
run out of three more mandalorians on a
landscape kind of like Mad Max Pirates a
roving gang of survivors who refused to
leave the planet after The Purge they
include actor Charles Parnell from Top
Gun Maverick he played Warlock and
Charles Baker he played skinny Pete on
Breaking Bad over dinner bocaton
confesses that she did surrender to moff
Gideon and there's a moment where casca
Reeves leans in to try to stop okay time
but Boca Town waves her off showing I
said this is the truth that these women
knew and shared with each other and
presumably ax woes did as well which
could be another reason why wolves might
have had a reason to betray her by
playing ball with Gideon like for Max
was one of you these two leaders are
equally bad but at least Gideon pays
better we also get some clarity on the
timeline of the night of a thousand
tiers incident first was the bombings
then there was a period of negotiation
between bocaton and the ISB and then
after she surrendered the dark saber to
moff Gideon then he betrayed her by
purging the planet anyway and so in that
book Boba Fett flashback that's the
point where we saw the droids going
through there with the best car helmets
in the ashes so the armor tells Warlock
and skinny Pete we were hidden on the
moon of Concordia are you death watch
DEATH watch exists no longer and behind
her I'm pretty sure that is the moon of
Concordia shining in the sky remember
earlier in the drop ship at least one of
them still had the Death Watch Sigil of
the SRI on their shoulders but we
definitely can read into the armor
saying the Death Watch exists no longer
especially with the horns on her helmet
in Clone Wars the members of the death
watch that served Maul had horns on
their helmets to pay respect to him and
in this episode MAF Gideon's new best
car armor has horns on the helmet could
part of the death watch ideology have
lived on in the armor I don't know I
just hope she's not Kira or something so
din tells Pokemon about the dark saber
saying I only know of this weapon what
you taught me to be honest it means
nothing to me or my people nor does
station or bloodline what means more to
me is honor and loyalty and character
it's interesting how in this episode The
darksaber is not used in any kind of
duel or conflict only as a means for the
mandalorians to retreat in Game survival
of one's people is the highest honor the
Pirates take him to the forge as the
armorer takes the wounded survivors and
The Gauntlet back up to the ship from
here forward the armor has sidelined
herself from the action and the episode
keeps cutting back to her as if
something might happen maybe a red
herring or maybe a reminder the armor
conveniently evaded Gideon's trap while
the others step right in it during a
chest like game X woes and possible in
it but a fight with vibroblades which
really get close looks here one framed
right in front of ax's Base the fight
rages on but grogu and the ig-12 suit
stops them
no no den says he didn't learn that for
me referring to grogu Zen training under
Luke Skywalker in the book of Boba Fett
chapter six remember all the character
development that happened in another
person's show a giant creature burst out
of the ground at first we thought of
mythosar but no it's just some other
Kaiju who might have also been awakened
by the bombings so uh mandalorians are
you sure you want to settle down here
this place kind of sucks the Survivor
urges them to go further into the caves
meaning this creature wrecked their ship
right by the exact place they needed to
go huh we see the ruins of the great
Forge looking a lot like the mines and
Fellowship of the Ring a once great
civilization wrecked by War and there
are piercing beams of light cutting
through the darkness just as there were
in Moria that's how they lit their way
through that Darkness then bescar
armored Imperial Stormtrooper sweep in
leading to the shootout two of the
Pirates get kicked off a ledge
one storm dripper gets lasted around the
neck and blown away via jet pack didn't
jar in clotheslines one of them in the
stomach and shoots him right between his
helmet and shoulder plating where his
neck would be exposed pokeaton shoots in
the same spot on another one because
they are Mandalorian they know better
exactly where the gaps in the armor are
so they get the imps on the run but one
must wonder if this retreat was
intentional as part of this overall trap
because In the Heat of the battle our
Mandos don't even realize that they've
transitioned from cave ruins to a
well-swept imperial Corridor it's a
haunted realization that they realized
too late when they see the Thai
interceptors hanging like freaking bats
here on their home planet that they've
been longing to reclaim they realize a
massive evil forces already set up shop
and moth Gideon descends in dark trooper
armor he declares his goal to take the
best of mandalorians the cloners and the
Jedi to serve the Next Generation
declaring their time is done basically
saying he's gonna appropriate all these
things to feed the first order he takes
din jar into a debriefing room you know
what that means hopefully borkellites
but bogoton refused to surrender the
darksaber as possible holds them all off
with his heavy repeating Blaster it
overheats so he takes out the rest by
hand Tate Fletcher just kicking ass and
taking names but those three praetorian
guards arrive and pause is no match
using their melee weapons purple ones
compared to the red glowing ones from
The Last Jedi they stab him in the gaps
of the armor under the breastplate in
the rib cage in the leg and in the
Shoulder Through the neck it's a tragic
end and so we're left with a question
who was that second spy I get the
suspicion toward the armor we talked
about that in Wookie leaks I just don't
know what she would have to gain from
working with Gideon or when she would
have had time to cast all that bescar
armor ax wolves was certainly motivated
and it was hard to clock exactly where
he was during this final Ambush we
should also look at those pirates they
did mysteriously survive on Mandalore
and let everyone directly into this trap
I went over me which Mandalorian do you
think has positive blood on their hands
whoever it was there is reason we saw
the mythosar at the beginning of the
season bogoton I believe is destined to
use this ancient creature to bring a
brutal into mop Gideon's attempt to fill
the power void among the Imperial
Warlords while I assume thrawn will
finally return in a post-credit scene
the only reason I can imagine for
Giancarlo s was either return this
season is to have it epic end where he
gets gobbled down or stomped by a
mythosar hey reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive and he
gets the furnace by grabbing some merch
at nerd riot.shop follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at eat a boss follow me
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]